do have three player chess
wait what
i just accept the challenge from grebel
wow
i don't know what it is but we'll find
out
wow
oh this is how the obvious works
wow oh my god what is this whoa
i don't know and i have one minute to
internalize what's going on
how many kings do
does tree have
yeah that's me
but that's the that's the ghost of shree
that's what it is
okay so i think all of us have to check
me at the king or what
how many kings can we checkmate
what is this
wait bizarre
i think we just take stuff
okay i have no idea what is this also
this is one minute
i can promote to a king
holy banana what yeah let's just i'll
promote the king
zombies
that way
we have no idea guys what is happening
you have no idea what is this
boy
and who is this green guy
it's the ghost
ghost guys ghost
eric what are you doing who's king are
you going after what am i not doing
why don't i have any nights oh yes i
finally got a night awesome
i think you gotta go with the king i
think it's better i don't know
this is so crazy
uh
there are mine squares oh my god it's
like an end game saying like
engaging oh it's mind yeah i didn't i
didn't i just noticed right now
i thought okay uh
okay this is like some
uh maze yeah
yeah some squares are off limits
why am i
zero
wow
wait
who is coming for my knight
how do we play this game wait what who
is this green why is he coming after me
so green is just like a robot zombie i
think that's tree
oh that's g
ghost of tree
yeah ghost street
okay i have no idea what i'm supposed to
do
wow
okay i'm going for him
just don't take my king
you're going for whom
i'm going for this green guy
this yeah i know guys this is not chess
i have no idea what is this
oh boy
oh yes
or don't yes thank you
this is so funny my king
oh boy
oh you still have a bunch of kings left
yeah okay another king is coming but why
do we promote to a king then
to keep your safe
wow
oh my god eric is just completely
killing it
i'm just eating food
wait what is this grains purpose
i don't understand at all this green
sparkles i don't understand at all
what is the purpose of this green
oh yes now i know the purpose
wait eric
what's that triple oh different ripple
fork
holy
maria
maria
triple check
ah so your king was originally worth
five points but now it's worth four
points because
you were checked i guess
not sure how that works but watch your
time dina
oh yes double check awesome
wow
wow oh you took the final piece
okay i'll just protect my king
not
playing this night
oh eric stop giving me checks i can't
hurt myself
it's not nice
yeah i don't know why i blended that
i was just stupid
very funny guys we have no idea what's
going on
that's true oh no eric
stop giving me checks
it's not nice
all my kings are coming the king is
coming
wow
okay it's coming guys it's coming
it's all good chill
the king is coming
for the mate
i don't know why i did that
oh eric give this blender a night yeah
[Music]
oh
dina is coming for my king
not this time dina yeah
i have learned my lesson
wow
oh no oh yes
oh this was not part oh
wow
oh actually we have to go after eric
here's to my points
please don't
oh nice move dina
nice move
oh no
why am i losing all the pieces
what are we doing with the kings
no idea
[Music]
eric has too many kings
i only have one king well who is harry
whose color is i regret wait dina has
three kings
[Laughter]
what is this mind square i don't
understand
oh thank you at it
shoot my knight
oh no my knight
what are kings for
can someone tell me
no idea
what are kings for
yeah this is like very confusing though
can king come to king
oh no wow
i pre-mode
wow
now i am like
this is so wild
oh boy
checking king with king yeah it's like
visit specialty
video specialty yeah checking king like
king
wow
is there a 50 move role in this game
only 75.
wow
oh no
oh no dina is coming for me
okay i'll just create a barrier
yes
yeah this
what is eric doing
he's just protecting his king yeah
not doing anything
wow okay eric i want to team up okay
let's team up
no
oh
wait no no don't worry dude
okay no i know the thing is i might have
to sacrifice
my king yeah for that so i don't know if
yeah no cannot do that
oh wait it's my mom okay
yeah what am i supposed to do ah okay i
think i got it yes got it
i think i know what i'm supposed to do
oh no
yes
oh yeah i still love this place
it's all good guys it's all good
wow
[Music]
wait what wow
[Music]
that was very brave
i don't know what happened
i could have done it wait wait what
happened
this was i could have done it oh my god
this was the ah wait how did you get
this was the whole my boy i realized
this was the whole point you know you
know you did it on purpose you did it on
purpose oh it's king of the house
main king today to the center
oh
i wasn't reading so i am grebel says
it's king of the hill
oh king of the hill
so you have to get to the king to the
center to like win i guess i was like my
best key was there
oh we were just roaming around
who was there
wait one thing isn't king of the hill
i'm so stupid i passed just by it kind
of
oh my god i just passed by it
was hilarious
that was fun
wait you are in out of focus in eric
twitch stream what is this eric very bad
yeah so
while you're [ __ ] on the zoom call
you're sharing
your stream layout so i had to like crop
your your face
and it's uh
your face is kind of small you did what
i
i cropped or i i enlarged your face
because your face is so small by the way
so people can still see generally what
you look like yeah it's fine guys fine
just kidding
uh he told me to switch on a new camera
and i did not so that's the punishment
yeah i'm trying to rub your head with my
cursor to
absorb your beast power
pretty much yeah that was a lot of fun
yeah this time
so now we understand like kind of the
the gist of this game
yeah let's do it
king of the hill with knights only
in kings
okay
people are like we want scribble but
guys nobody draws wait what is this wait
wait wait where is this night coming
from
welcome
it's coming from a place of love
please don't know
wait why am i losing all the pieces this
is not part of the plan
this is clearly not such a short time
this green is against me i think
oh yes thank god i was worried
yes that's better that's better guys
yeah this night came out of nowhere yeah
i was like what then
oh wait
i thought he won't take my knight
okay i have no idea what's up
it's super hard to follow
i was just sure
that it's great nights okay guys i think
we need to team up okay scream guys yeah
let's all be friends against trees
ghosts
also this green guy yeah why is he
coming after me like it's not fair
it's not fair at all
i'm the weakest now
yeah guys
uh do you want to
play this what is that
scribble or something we also don't have
much time this is uh this is better yeah
yeah yeah guys we don't know much tricky
we'll do it sometime when c is free no
no no we don't have much time on the
clock
oh that too yeah
you don't have much time on the clock
yeah okay got it
i know what that is
so it's basically you have to draw and
the other people guess actually
yeah guys they don't know it's fine
don't take my king please just give him
some check
someone give him a check otherwise he'll
take my king okay
he's protective
he's super protective
oh eric take this knight take that
stupid knight
doesn't deserve to be in this game
okay
it's your turn don't don't listen to him
don't listen to him nothing
i have nothing to do with this game i'm
just gonna i must say it's so funny that
we do not play against each other we
play against this uh
green
even if we wanted we wouldn't because we
would be too focused on the green guy
yeah like eric's night is getting in my
way eric please move your knight
don't worry
okay wait
or no this is horrible oh it's finally
finally
my king is coming guys my king is coming
wait eric is winning our world
oh eric is going after all the kings
beautiful
not your main king no that's my that's
my one licking
oh so you cannot go there until it's
protected
oh okay now i understand
i think
yeah okay
okay
oh no my headache
oh no my eric i just realized my pawn
can't move
oh
someone take on eric's knights
they don't deserve
wait like oh oh i okay oh this king i
have to be very careful oh i'm sorry
plus 20
wait why is my king out because you i
checked you five times
and then you it's i guess
i guess
guys
that was a pleasure collaborating with
you
oh
so all you have to do is cross the rink
oh
dina's so strong
you're welcome you're welcome